hey everybody
time for a movie retrospective once
again this is the one everybody voted
for again again this one won by just one
vote
yeah there's a little classic here i
love this movie this is early 90s or was
it 89 89 89
[ __ ] i didn't even have to re-watch
this one for the show i would have
yeah but i just watched it a couple uh
weeks ago
yeah so um so i was like i don't even
have to because i think i have this
movie
[ __ ] memorized because i've seen it
so many times this is the
1989 black comedy heathers
i remember we used to i used to rent
this i think i read it
two or three times on vhs back in the
day when it was still kind of new
but i don't really think i saw it until
like maybe 1990
yeah well that's only a year after it
came out yeah i think that's when i saw
it i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty sure i saw this in the
theater i was a junior in high school
when this came out so this would have
been like right in the wheelhouse and
like right around the time that we were
going to the movies all the time
and i was right like smack dab in the
target demographic for this
me and my friends it's weird i didn't
even know until
recently because heathers has like
infiltrated the culture
to such an extent that i was actually
blown away when i was
researching the movie and found out that
this was actually a box office
flop it cost three million dollars to
make it and it only made 1.1 million
back
it didn't start to get its cult
following until it came out on vhs
and everybody rented it and saw it and
realized
that that's the thing about movies like
this
dark comedy black comedy is always a
hard
sell and i think that the way that they
marketed it
that it looked like another teen movie
like in the john hughes kind of vein
so when people actually saw it they were
kind of
horrified because i liked it though i
did as well me and my friends
[ __ ] loved this movie we just
we like quoted it all the time talking
about a movie kind of like breakfast
club or
pretty impaired it's a parody of that
but it had a serial killer in it
you know and and everybody was cute in
it
everybody looked good and had good music
and ever and it was
it was just the setting was you know it
was upper middle class setting you know
white people and it was just
that's what you watched back in the day
well and like i said the guy that wrote
it
i love this and this was another thing
that i didn't know yeah
so the guy that wrote it daniel waters
this was his first screenplay that he
had written he wrote it when he was 23.
and so he was in touch with he wrote it
yeah
and he was the he's like this is how
pretentious and like full of myself i
was when i was 23 when i wrote this
the original screenplay for this was
three hours long
and he wanted stanley kubrick to direct
it yeah
which now i kind of want to see that
well because he
he justified it by saying well stanley
kubrick did his horror movie he did his
war movie he did is you know he did like
every genre
and he's like he this would have been
his teen movie well um
as it happened obviously stanley kubrick
did not direct this movie although like
i said now i kind of want to go to that
alternate universe where that happened
but one of the sequences
in heather's like the slow-motion
cafeteria thing
um they actually put that in there as an
homage to full metal jacket
because the guy that wrote this was
really into stanley kubrick so now like
i said i'm
really interested to know how
millennials and younger react to this
movie nowadays because to me
okay so here the plot of this movie
there are there's a high school called
westerberg high school which yes was
named after paul westerberg from the
replacements because one underwriter was
a big fan of theirs
and so veronica played by winona ryder
she is kind of the odd man out of this
clique of
mean girls called the heathers and their
names are all heather heather duke
heather chandler and heather mcnamara
they're just your standard you know high
school [ __ ]
uh you know everyone either wants to be
them or wants to
you know but they're like terrible to
everybody they're just like these
horrible conscience look you're asking
about what
what you think millennials and gen z you
know what they would think of this
i would think that they kind of like it
but they like i think because it's alien
there is an 80s revival thing going on
in music and style and it's
well and like that wasn't exactly what i
meant but
yeah i'll get into it there's been a
revival in that
but but the thing is is that the way we
grew up is very different and i think
the school situation and the scene in a
high school today is probably very
different from what we grew up in
but it was a pre-internet era
and a lot of you know you had to
socialize face to face with people
back in those days which could cause a
lot of problems
that's what that was but it was good too
it was rewarding and punishing that's
just
where you learned how to deal with
people you know for the first time
as young adults in high school so
i don't know i don't think they'd like
this movie in some ways
i was i was curious to see so i watched
like some
you know younger film reviewers and it
was kind of 50 50 like some of them
really really loved it and some of them
because of the way that and and some
critics when this came out
um accused it of making light of
suicide and murder um you know school
shootings and stuff like that now when
this came out school
shootings were not all that common um so
that's what i'm thinking now it's like
now that they
have there have been so many of them in
the ensuing years that maybe people
you know would see this differently or
would see the movie as like making light
of that
it's not because it's a black comedy
it's parodying
it's parodying the john hughes thing and
it's parodying the attitudes
that adults have toward teenagers toward
teenage suicide toward the cliques or
everything like that so
but it's a very vicious satire and i
feel like the only
really the only later movies that were
kind of like this it was jawbreaker
which came out in the
90s i can't remember what rose mcgowan
was in that it was 96 i want to say
maybe it was later
um that was kind of a ripoff of this um
most people will mention mean girls from
2004 but mean girls is pretty tame
um compared to this one so basically you
got your
heathers your group who also has a
veronica who's like i said she
she seems like they imply that they kind
of plucked her
and like made her one of the heathers
you know what i mean but she's still
kind of like ambivalent about it because
she doesn't like
the cruelty they display so she's you
know she likes being popular but
in a way she doesn't really like it so
there is uh this new guy who comes to
the school
jason dean also known as jd uh who is
christian slater channeling
jack nicholson which he did on purpose
uh so
it's not like it was an accident or
anything so he comes to the school and
basically his first action
is these two jocks come over and start
teasing him or like bullying and calling
him a [ __ ] or whatever
good hair because he had good hair and a
nice trench coat and he basically stands
up with a
gun and shoots both of them yeah it was
a cult python
but it was it had blanks in it though
you find out later that it was blanks
and like i said i think that this is the
way this kind of plays differently
nowadays because just the next scene the
girls are like
you know oh they should throw his ass in
jail he used a real gun
but then veronica went on a writer's
character says
oh he used blanks all he did was ruin
two pairs of pants you know
implying that the two jocks [ __ ]
themselves so the fact that he doesn't
get i mean he i don't think he got
suspended or anything like for basically
shooting two guys at the face of the
blanket it's a different culture but
that's what i'm saying so it's like it
doesn't really play the same nowadays as
it did back then
i guess it was a totally different value
system back then and
you know it had it was a mixed bag and
certain some ways it was a better time
yes me uh at least in my my personal
experience
but like i said they weren't i don't
feel like this movie is making light of
it yes it's a black comedy yes it's a
satire
but it's not saying it's it's not siding
with
jason dean he's clearly a psychopath
yeah but you know
coming up in high school you know
[ __ ] in in trenton high
and out in michigan and also scholar got
a lot of sao paulo and brazil
me growing up in those high schools we
had dudes like that
there were psychos in [ __ ] school
well yeah but they tended to get better
or they left or they went to jail
you had that [ __ ] yeah you had that [ __ ]
and then well you have that now
that's what i'm saying it's a normal
part of life yeah and that was part of
growing up and we also had suicides
and you know what be to be honest we
didn't give [ __ ]
well that [ __ ] girl about [ __ ] five
lockers down for me killed herself and
we
and then the day went on like nothing
the next day we're going in
killed herself one of the main things
that this movie is
poking not necessarily poking fun of but
they're kind of like
they're kind of showing how you know all
the adults in the school for example
like you know what the plot of this
movie is if you haven't seen it
is that veronica starts hooking up with
jason dean because she's like ooh the
bad boy thing
and they uh she has a fight with
heather number one heather chandler who
like i said they're frenemies basically
um she has a fight with her and she
basically
offhand says you know i wish she was
dead or something like that and jason
dean is like
can do and uh so they go to her house
the next day
all veronica initially wants to do is
give her something that'll make her puke
because you know veronica puked at the
party the night before and embarrassed
you know heather and like blah blah
so it's just supposed to be revenge but
jason dean instead
switches the cups out or doesn't say
when veronica has switched the cups
one of the cups has drain cleaner in it
and basically the girl dies
so veronica flips out but jason dean is
like
well why don't we just like forge a
suicide note so it looks like she just
chucked she and she just you know
chugged drain cleaner and crashed
through a glass coffee table
so they basically you know forge a
suicide note
now the weird thing that happens after
that is that everyone buys it
but veronica points out that now
heather chandler is more popular than
she was when she was alive
because after she died because she wrote
this really nice note about us like
nobody knew the real me
people think your life is so easy when
you're pretty and rich and everything
and so it gave heather chandler a soul
like you know posthumously and then
it almost comes a kind of thing where
people start
killing themselves just to be like the
cool kids
so that's kind of like as i said that's
what this is parodying it's
it's like a john hughes movie but all of
the characters in it are like
grotesque like over you know what i mean
like not well
you know what you know what was
happening i remember i was there at the
time in high school you know
it was a few years before this came out
but society hadn't changed much in a
couple years
you had a bunch of [ __ ] real touchy
feely [ __ ]
people in the teachers unions that kept
[ __ ] talking about suicide
and kept [ __ ] harping on it and
most of the students laughed it off they
were just thought they were you know
basically like [ __ ] that they're [ __ ]
you know what i mean we're talking about
the teachers
yeah so it ended up becoming kind of
like we ridiculed our teachers in our
times behind their backs a lot of times
we didn't
well i think they still we didn't
believe anything that they said we
didn't accept any of their values we
didn't
we we gave a [ __ ] what what they
believed
and we had all kinds of stuff going on
and it depends on which high school i'm
talking about
in brazil those teachers were terrified
of the students they wouldn't get
involved they wouldn't tell them
anything
because the brazilian ones all their
parents were
powerful military powerful members in
the ex in the military junta
or or the [ __ ] dictatorship that just
stepped down or
they were in the new democracy that was
coming and they were all gangsters all
right so
they wouldn't say [ __ ] to a student um
they were servants basically that's what
teachers were
in that school the in the in the uh
in the school outside of detroit
it was just about it we just didn't
believe what they said because you know
they were
or we didn't care what they said it was
just kind of this touchy feely fake
but like i said drugs that's kind of
like so that's what we just left that's
been like that like forever
it's still like that now it was like
that back you know what they were
talking about um
you know treated you like they didn't
you didn't know what pot was
yeah yeah that's what i mean and that's
in this this is kind of parodying that
in this
movie too because they have a lot of
adult figures like they have
um the one female teacher who's kind of
like she's the art teacher is kind of
like a hippie
uh they call her miss flem and she's
kind of one of those
you know we need to have like all this
stuff about you know because all these
teenagers are hurting and they're all
killing themselves and
blah blah so she needs to have this
thing and so she's kind of the one that
they all make fun of
um one of my favorite when they're
having like the meeting in there and
she's like we have to revel in this
moment and we have to have a meeting and
everything and then the principal's like
call me when the shuttle lands you know
i made it like really [ __ ] so it's
like
so they have that but they also have
these other kind of like
mercenary sort of teachers that he's
like well now this one that killed us
was she a cheerleader and they're like
no that's the other heather and he's
like damn i'd be willing to go whole day
for a cheerleader to like let the
students go home
so it's like they're just showing that
all the adults don't really give a [ __ ]
it's all just about like optics yeah so
that's a good way to put it it was
optics even back then
yeah so that's what i mean so so that's
kind of where it's coming from
yeah now um as it goes on so like i said
the heather number one
uh gets murdered but it looks like a
suicide then
uh jd decides after the two jocks that
initially made fun of him that he
kind of like pretended to shoot in the
face um they do some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and so he decides he's gonna kill them
as well he gets veronica in on it
by basically saying and i love this he
says uh he's loading the gun
and she's like um no we're not gonna do
this like we're not gonna kill it you
know my body and clyde days are over she
says
and he says do you take german and she
said no french and he says these are
ichlooga
bullets ichaluga means i'm lying
so but she didn't know that so he's like
yeah they just uh they're like
tranquilizers they just pierce the skin
and makes it looks like
you know it just knocks them out it
doesn't really kill them but of course
that wasn't
uh that wasn't what they did so
basically what they did with the two
football players curtin ram
was that because they were so homophobic
because they were so everyone's a big
[ __ ] [ __ ]
like that they decided after they killed
them that they were going to make it
look like they killed themselves because
it was like a repressed homosexual pact
so it's like he left like this made
sense to the cops this bag there
yeah i love that scene i have to say i
love that scene where they the cops like
find the the two dead guys like in their
underwear
yeah like in the bag there's like an
issue of stud puppy
yeah and then like christian slater like
when he's saying all the stuff that he
got he's like here's the one perfected
thing i picked up
mineral water and like winona ryder is
like what are you talking about
it's like you know one a lot of people
drink mineral water and he's like
yeah but this is ohio if you don't have
a brewski in your hands you might as
well be wearing a dress
so um and that's exactly what the cops
think it's like
oh they didn't water they were bags they
shot each other you know what i mean
and then there's that great [ __ ]
scene at the funeral where like the two
jocks they're like are in the coffins
they have their football helmets out of
the footballs and then the dad's crying
he's like i love bened gay son
you know what i mean yeah and it's like
it's just it's terrible but it's like
[ __ ] hilarious i mean the movie like
i said you have to
you have to understand this is a satire
so it's
like there's gonna be some like [ __ ]
up [ __ ] in it i remember
remember watching it you know fresh out
of high school but really when you look
at the big picture i was fresh out of
high school in 1990
yeah i was still in high school and i
graduated and i've been out a couple
years but it still felt like you were in
high school
even though you weren't in it anymore
anyway uh you still thought that way a
little bit
i i just the whole thing resonated with
me like those scenes
i was like oh yeah it was just
it's a different era i mean nowadays
people might get offended
but no that was the way reality was well
like i said it's a satire
it's over the top deliberately so yeah
um
you know like i said it's almost like
grotesque like parody of like high
school yeah like
because everybody can relate especially
people that have been picked on
um you know because i didn't
particularly like jocks or anything like
that in school either
so you could you could see getting
sucked into this kind of thing like with
jd and like killing these people and
being like oh it's worth it
but at heart i mean veronica eventually
like realizes hey this dude's a
psychopath and it's like i have to like
you know break this up i have to stop
him so
it's almost saying that even though jd's
character
is supposedly um you know all these
clicks and they're you know it he's
basically like saying that's
evil and i'm gonna fix it but he's just
as bad if not worse than they are
because he's actually
killing people um you know and saying
that he's like an edgelord basically
is uh he's a very early like edgelord
prototype
um but but you can see how like his
character is very alluring at the
beginning
because he's taken out the people that
you want taken out because that you feel
like they deserve it
but like i said in the end it seems like
he's like worse than they are because he
at the end basically you know spoiler
alert he wants to blow up the whole
school
he like puts bombs but yeah he's got
he's got a high level of charisma and
charisma right can get you through a lot
for a little
time before people realize women this
[ __ ] is dangerous
you know well yeah that's exactly what
this movie is talking about
and uh just in a funny way go back and
watch those two
those two [ __ ] columbine kids if you
know the whole
story yeah they were [ __ ] up but they
had a lot of charisma themselves too
you know um they felt they were being it
was vengeance you know they thought they
were being
treated and that's yeah they wanted to
kill everybody that's a that's a [ __ ]
way over-the-top reaction to it but
they're kids man they don't [ __ ] know
they don't understand
yeah the gravity of what they're what
they're doing
and then by the time they're doing it
it's too late yeah they can't
back out well like i said that's kind of
sure essentially
what i mean i think jd's character in
this movie is like a more charismatic
version of
one of the columbine shooters just
because he justified it by saying you
know they're
all all this power hierarchy in this
school and like they're all snotty and
they're cruel to everybody so they
deserve it
um and then we can kill them and make it
look like suicides and we'll get away
with it yeah
and so like i said for a time it's
almost kind of like you want
them to be the heat like him to be the
hero but he's not not really
he's not but there's something true
about the movie
yeah is that these guys that do this
they're not a lot of times at that age
they're not monstrous
they're just regular people like the
columbine guys
had they made it out of high school
without doing that
mass shooting eventually they just would
have been normal people
it just happened to be they drove each
other
to it was a synergy they drove each
other to do it
and then it's too late by the time you
started doing it well yeah because the
thing about teenage
guys is that they don't just hormonally
and they don't really
mature until they're like my older and
then but like if they did something
[ __ ] up when they were routine they're
just too late let's do that and you
can't fix it it was almost kind of like
a natural disaster where
was it a dick move yeah it was a dick
move uh
very much dick move that's that was the
understatement yes that's right but
they're
they're crazy yeah they're under the
influence of all these [ __ ] hormones
and [ __ ] it's a bad environment or
it's
people [ __ ] with them and that's how
they exploded into that [ __ ]
and they talked each other into it took
them a long time to do it yeah
they talked each other into that yeah
and um it was basically a suicide pact
kamikaze suicide pact
but like i said had they made it out of
high school
within a year so they didn't spend no
they would have just probably grown
out of it yeah they'd have been up at
the club hanging out which is sad
yeah but um but yeah so basically so the
end of this movie like i said veronica
realizes that she has to stop him from
doing what he's doing
um she fakes her own suicide to keep him
from killing her
and then basically she goes and she
finds out like about this plot he's
gonna blow up the whole school like
during a pep rally he's planting all
these bombs like underneath because his
dad's a psychopath too and his dad like
goes and blows up buildings
except he does it legally um yeah so so
veronica basically goes to the school
and uh is able to stop him and she saves
the entire school i have to say
and i'll get into this in a minute but
there were a couple of alternate endings
which
i kind of wish i could have seen but i
do like the way this ends
where she stops him from blowing up the
school but then he essentially straps
the bomb onto himself
and comes out into the yard and uh he's
gonna blow himself
up and she all she does is just look at
him like yeah whatever and she takes out
a cigarette and puts it in her mouth
now this is um a reference back to a
time
where after she has discovered that
they've actually killed
kurt and ram the two football players
she
as punishment she takes the you know the
car lighter out and she burns herself
she's like self-harming
and christian slater jd like just takes
her hand and lights his cigarette with
it
like to kind of show his callousness or
whatever that um
that she feels bad about it so she's
showing hey you know you're going to
blow yourself up and i'm just going to
see her and light my cigarette off it so
how do you like it so i kind of like
that ending
now originally though there were two
different
alternate endings for this uh in one of
the endings
the the ending that was actually
supposed to be in the movie was that
jd was actually going to succeed in
blowing up the school and everyone was
going to die
and then they were all and then there
was going to be a final scene of all of
the students in heaven
and they were finally all getting along
like all the different cliques were
getting along but they were all dead
uh the other alternate ending was
um was martha dunstalk known as martha
dumptruck in the movie like the
the very large uh obese woman she was
actually going to stab
veronica to death and was she was going
to stab her
and um then she was going to call her
heather and i think the last line of the
movie was veronica saying my name's not
heather you [ __ ]
so uh i like both of those endings but
actually i really like the way they
ended it where she kind of she saved
everybody but also like jd blew himself
up
now um as i said this movie
when it came out i was a junior in high
school me and my friends [ __ ] adored
it
we didn't really realize that it didn't
do that well at the box office like i
said it's not that unusual for black
comedies they're a very hard sell a lot
of people don't like them
um but over the years like you know on
the rental it like really ended up
making a lot of money
and then it seeped so much into the
public consciousness
that the slang that's in it
which uh was mostly made up because the
guy that wrote the screenplay was like
well i don't want to put
you know current slang in it because
it'll date the movie so i basically want
to
make up my own you know the my own way
that they talk
so then that way it's can't be like
placed in a certain time period
so you know stuff like saying oh it's so
very um you know [ __ ] me gently with a
chainsaw like all the kind of stuff that
they said
um was basically like you know made up
or he just took it from like people that
he knew
and i've read somewhere maybe it was on
the wikipedia
page that this movie is so
quotable and all the [ __ ] that was in it
like seeped so much into the
public vernacular that this is actually
one of the most cited
films in the oxford english dictionary
just because it added like so many words
and phrases
like to to slang which like that [ __ ]
kills me i think it's an important movie
it is just because it's like a snapshot
in time
of the thinking of the very late 80s it
very late 80s early 90s that was kind of
the gestalt of the time
you know what i mean at least for from
the point of view of a teenager or some
person in their early 20s it's uh
it's a good peer it's a good look into
the psychology of the time i think
and honestly i still i just watched it a
couple weeks ago and it's still funny as
hell today
i mean like i said it is probably the
darkest
high school satire i've ever seen the
only other one that comes close is maybe
election
with reese witherspoon i think was in it
um that was pretty dark too
but this one's pretty dark like i said
it's a like [ __ ] murder suicide like
all kind of [ __ ] they made for
bulimia there's like all kind of [ __ ]
they're making fun of i don't think
they'll ever
be a movie like this made again it's a
it's a high quality movie it's shot very
well it's got really good uh
music in it but it's so offbeat
you know what i mean you're never gonna
have topics like this
and scenes like this merged with this
type of
high quality i don't think they'll do it
again i mean they made
okay there was an off-broadway version
of this uh
that came out in 2010 and ran for
several years which i've heard was
actually very good
and there was actually a song in it
called i love my dead gay son which i
thought was hilarious
they also did a series based on it
um starting in 2014 2016 i want to say
i'm not sure if it's still on um it was
kind of controversial it came out was
like delayed because
like um it was the parkland shooting or
stoneman douglas or something like that
when that shooting they had kind of had
to delay it because they were like oh
it's like sensitive material or whatever
but i think it did subsequently come out
i've heard mixed reviews of it some
people really like it some people
didn't like it the writer actually said
he thought it was a little weird for the
first four episodes but then it got like
a lot better
so like i said this is still pretty
culturally relevant um i founded a bunch
of like cool
[ __ ] [ __ ] about this so winona ryder
who
for some reason i thought she was older
than high school age when i saw this
movie because she's not
she's she's a kid she was 15 or 16 when
she made this movie cute is a bug too
she wanted this role so
bad and so she basically went to the
writers like please please please let me
be in this movie
and originally they didn't want her to
be the lead because they thought she
quote unquote wasn't pretty enough
crazy well because i guess they wanted
like the heathers they wanted them to
look like
all because all the other ones were kind
of blonde or shannon doherty was in it
she was kind of redheaded
they were all just these beautiful
wealthy kind of there's probably more to
it than that
well well she said i looked like a like
gothi
and you know what i mean because
beetlejuice came out like right around
the same time or the year before
and um so she went and got a makeover
and then they finally gave it to her and
she said
she said they wanted jennifer connelly
actually is who they wanted or justine
bateman
uh those were the those were the two
that were in the running wouldn't have
been the same movie i don't think it
would have been the same and and i think
that the writer and the
director like after it came out they
were just like winona brought something
to it that was just
like one of those happy accidents like
we didn't want her initially but then
when she was in it
and when owner writer said that when she
was like she was begging to be in this
movie her agent said
she said my agent got down on her knees
and said please
do not do this movie you will never work
again
[ __ ] and that's yeah that's not how
it turned out
um but it's funny how many actresses
turned down this movie for various
reasons because i think one of the um
heather chandler heather number one the
part of that they originally wanted that
to go to heather graham
um but heather graham was only 17 at the
time
and her parents would not let her be in
it because they read the script and
they're just like oh no
she's not doing that and the weird thing
is that heather graham a few years later
played a porn star in boogie nights yeah
she was roller girl
and it's like but her parents were still
like under cause she was a minor
um and the funny thing too is that
shannon dougherty is in this and this
was pre-90210 i think it was like a year
or two
before but shannon dougherty had been
working in tv since she was
a little kid so she was like kind of a
pro now
she would not say any swear words
in this like because some of the lines
in this like [ __ ] me
gently with a chainsaw she was supposed
to say that but she wouldn't say it so
they had to give it to another character
and the funny thing about this this is
how the story goes
is that she didn't actually know that
this was a black comedy
until she watched it afterward and she
was really upset
she thought it was a drama but the
director thought that was really funny
because they're like we liked that she
played it straight the whole time like
you know she wasn't trying to be funny
she wasn't trying to be in a comedy so
she played it like in a very straight
way
and we think it came out like a lot
better but apparently i think she's over
it now but she kind of uh you know
she she didn't know that it's a weird
kind of movie i liked it
i don't think there'll ever be another
movie really kind of like this uh
in terms of like with like i said with
the quality you probably
would see something that was like uh
an indie film it would be like this but
yeah but this doesn't have an
indie film film feel at all
it feels like it's like a john hughes
movie except a much
more [ __ ] up surreal version for me it
was just like a mainstream american
movie
yeah and uh but it was a highly
subversive
and it was subversive then probably even
more subversive now i mean it's not pc
well and like i said i think the closest
movie to it
more recently was mean girls and mean
girls is pretty tame
compared to this one um but as i said
they did do like an off-broadway play
they did do a series based on this that
was you know
that had a lot of the same [ __ ] in it so
it's like they do kind of
have a thing it kind of had some action
at the end too
with the whole bomb thing and everything
you know it was it's not just like a
teen
comedy it is but it isn't it's just it's
weird
but yeah like i said it's a very it's
one of it's one of the most vicious
satires i've ever seen and
also and it also has like some
surrealism in it too
yeah you know what i mean which i think
is kind of cool now one like sad thing
the the woman that played um heather
chandler heather number one kim walker
now she was actually dating christian
slater at the time that they were
filming this movie although they broke
up later
do you want to hear something [ __ ] up
i don't know if you guys know this or
not but you know how she has the line in
the movie where she asks
uh heather heather duke shannon
dougherty's character did you have a
brain tumor for breakfast
well guess what guess what kim walker
died of a brain tumor when she was 32
years old isn't that [ __ ] up and it's
like i don't know that just like creeped
me out for some reason
i didn't even realize that she was dead
and she
you know that i don't know yeah
well it's weird because we know one that
died of a brain tumor about that age my
uncle died of a brain tumor at that age
isn't that strange
what was that he was thinking what was
he named jennifer what was the
the one that yeah from the club jenna
she was no she was 29 she's 29 28 29
yeah she was healthy and stuck
talking and hanging out with us and then
like a couple weeks later she died
yeah it was weird it's really freaky
yeah weird that's
yeah really funny and apparently they
knew about it they knew that that was in
there
yeah they didn't take it out for some
reason well maybe they couldn't maybe
they could
yeah because some of them are like so
deep in there that's like you know
there's no way to get it out because
like i said that's what happened to my
uncle as well
right like they just couldn't get to it
but yeah it's like if you
if you like teen comedies but with
this like with an edge and probably the
biggest edge of any teen comedy like i
said election comes close
but it's not quite as vicious as this
one
but i think that's what made it like
really really funny to me
like i just i love this movie i could
watch it every day for the rest of my
life and never get bored of it i could
it's one it's one of those movies where
and like i said i think i have it
memorized at this point like all the
[ __ ] lines in it and everything
because i've seen it so many times but
it's just it's a [ __ ] classic and if
you haven't seen it you definitely
definitely should
and if you're younger i'd be curious
like what you
think about it if you've seen it or if
you go watch it and then
it's on shutter now i think and it might
be some other places too
but yeah go check it out and tell me
what you think
and we'll see you on the next one bye